MIKE WOLFE: Can we
look around in here?
SAM: Oh, absolutely, yeah.
MIKE WOLFE: Wow, this is packed!
Dang, man, this is crazy.
SAM: Lots and lots.
MIKE WOLFE: So you must have
bought everything gas and oil
within like a 50 mile radius.
SAM: Or a 100 mile.
- No doubt.
SAM: Yeah, my wife
might call it hoarding,
but I never thought that.
I just thought I was
saving it from oblivion.
Because a lot of this stuff
disappeared, got scrapped.
And if I could save
it by collecting it,
that's another benefit too.
You know this
sign's next level?
I mean, the quality of this--
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Can I pull this out?
- Absolutely, yes.
Look at that!
SAM: When I was a kid, Flying
A was all over the place.
MIKE WOLFE: That
was the stuff, man.
SAM: Yeah, that was my
favorite to look at,
the graphics and everything.
MIKE WOLFE (VOICEOVER):
Up into the 1960s,
the winged A of
Flying A gas was one
of the most iconic logos and
one of the most iconic brands.
MIKE WOLFE: Where
did you find this?
SAM: North Carolina.
- No kidding?
- Yeah, yeah.
So you were on the
road looking for stuff?
I was on the road, also,
if I was on vacation.
I'd vacation in North Carolina.
I'd drive 200 miles
in a circle sometimes.
Yeah.
WOMAN: So these
kids get in the car,
they think they're
going to the beach.
And all of a sudden,
their beach day
is interrupted because Dad
found a cool Coke machine.
- This sign's next level.
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean, it's not
in mint condition.
SAM: No, it's not, right.
MIKE WOLFE: But I mean, it's
embossed, it's the Flying A--
SAM: Yeah, it is.
MIKE WOLFE: --the wings
coming off of the circle.
I mean, this is--
Yeah, my eyes popped
out when I saw that.
Yeah, this is it.
Yeah, so it's one
of my favorite things.
It took a long time
to find that piece.
I always wanted
one of those signs.
I used to see them
before I could buy one.
So I traveled hundreds
of miles to get that.
And I really, really
like that piece.
MIKE WOLFE: Is this
something you'd sell?
I've never parted
with anything,
never sold one thing, so--
- You never sold one thing?
- No, not one.
I'm thinking when-- when
am I going to do it?
And I never thought
I'd come to this day.
So I started thinking
about it recently,
and there's no better time.
This is it, you know?
- This is it for you.
- Yeah, this is it.
- This is the moment.
Yeah.
MIKE WOLFE: What
are you thinking
on something like this?
I don't know.
What would you--
It's a prime piece,
it's really beautiful.
It is, it's awesome.
MIKE WOLFE (VOICEOVER):
I want to throw
a number out there that's
going to get his attention.
$3,500.
That was way more
than I paid for it.
I didn't expect that.
It's like, wow.
I think the retail on it's
probably $4,000 to $4,200,
$4,300.
Yeah.
So I can just see
his brain working.
Which one of your children
do you get rid of first?
MIKE WOLFE: I mean,
what were you thinking?
Around $3,600.
He knew.
He knew that sign.
When you're giving something to
somebody, or parting with it,
whatever, it being
monetary or not,
you want them to really like it.
And I felt that.
I love, man.
Seriously.
- Wow.
- I mean, thank you.
I know-- I know what it means.
I never knew what it felt
like to part with something.
It felt so different.
I wish I could have conveyed the
emotion I felt at that moment.
It felt like to start
of something new.
And it's funny it
started with that sign.
I'm a collector myself.
When you let something
like this go--
It's been a lot of years.
I know, man, I know.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
- Thank you.
- What do you value this at?
$1,500.
How about $900?
How about $1,000.
$950.
Sold.
Yes.
Are we doing it?
Sam is the only
collector in this family.
He doesn't have a
whole lot of people
to share this with, to
talk about this with.
This one's is rough.
Right.
But it's still cool, man.
I mean, how long
have you had this?
Where'd you get this?
20 years ago in
Hillsdale, New Jersey.
So it wasn't far.
Did you dig it out of ground?
No, I found it
behind a gas station.
A guy had it, and I saw
it from the train one day.
MIKE WOLFE: Really?
- Yeah.
You never know where the next
one's going to hit you, man.
No.
MIKE WOLFE: You got that radar.
There's the money
shot right there.
Yeah, yeah.
I really wanted the Pegasus.
I don't have a
Pegasus, never had one,
and they were
always out of reach.
This was a way for me to
have almost a Pegasus.
500 bucks.
Yes.
OK, here we go.
It's the Mobil pile.
WOMAN: So to have two
people, even strangers,
come onto his property
and geek out with him
over all of his cool memories--
Texaco!
SAM: I took it off the pole.
The pole was laying down.
I couldn't take the pole
because it was too big.
MIKE WOLFE: I know.
SAM: I would have
loved to have the pole.
MIKE WOLFE: I've been there.
SAM: It was it the Hobo
Deli, I remember that.
[laughter]
MIKE WOLFE: $800?
$900?
$850?
$850.
All right, you going to
help me get it out of there?
Yeah.
WOMAN: That's why we collect,
so that we can talk to people
about it, so that we
can feel other people's
excitement as well.